وقع الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير زيلينس
اتفاقا مع رئيس الوزراء البولندي لتوريد
حزمه دفاعيه جديده ستحمى وصفها بحريه
واستقلال اوكرانيا وبولندا واوروبا
والعالم باسره وشدد زيلينسكي على ضروره ان
يكون هناك تحالف طيران لصالح اوكرانيا على
غرار تحالف الدبابات
عندما تتطلب المعركه استخدام المدفعيه
فيجب توفيرها عندما يحتاج النصر الى
الدبابات يجب سماعها ديرها على خط
المواجهه وعندما يحتاج الاستقلال الى
الاجواء فلا داعي للاهتمام بكيفيه رد فعل
روسيا على اعطاءنا الطائرات لا تفعل ذلك
فكروا في اعداد الناس الذين سيكونون اكثر
امانا بجانب الرمز اف 16 او غيره تصرفوا
تماما كما تجلت قيادتكم في تحالف الدبابات
اعتقد انها ستظهر نفسها ايضا في تحالف
الطيران هذه معركه الحريه ولا يمكن الفوز
بها بشكل مجتزا
[موسيقى]